foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's
whatever day it is Tuesday it's Tuesday
yeah that's right I couldn't remember
yeah and we're doing uh time Badness a
movie that I didn't get a chance to see
last night really good yeah every
[ __ ] thing that happened so
I had to
cook
and then it turns out that the iceman
the ice maker broke
and I had to we were devastated yes
for about a year Frigidaire ice maker
and it stopped [ __ ] the little tray
stopped moving right
I cleaned it because it was filthy up in
there and then it Trace stopped moving
right
and I took it apart and found it just a
little tiny piece of plastic that that
motor turns inside that tray had
stripped out and there was no real way
to fix it without replacing that tray
and I was like man I hate to [ __ ] go
through this [ __ ] just replacing these
trays although you know what I didn't
throw it away it's on the back porch I
could always fix it I guess yeah I mean
we could always have two
right it's easy to fix everything else
is running good it's just that that
little ice cube tray came became
stripped out on one end and it's like a
two dollar part
ain't that something yeah
well that's always the way so I had to
order another one 115 and it's red yeah
we got the bread it's a different it's a
different brand but
um I looked into it and they're kind of
all like uh [ __ ]
private labeled ones you know what I
mean they're not really made by
Frigidaire they're all made by the same
company they just put different they're
all about the same they put different
outside and skins on them and different
names on them but they're all basically
the same ice maker so that'll be in
tomorrow
but yeah so that's the thing because I
like by the time we finished everything
up like by the time we finished doing
the stream and then I had to like do
some other [ __ ] afterward and then he
started going down cooking and that took
a really long time and then trying to
fix ice maker and then he was trying to
fix the ice maker and I was like it was
getting to be like 9 9 30 and I was like
dude this movie's like two hours long so
it's like I really have to like watch it
before I fall asleep so that red legit
so I just watched it like he came in and
out and like watched it it kind of sucks
because I kind of wanted you to see it
because you like Terry Gilliam yeah look
like a real good movie it kind of I love
this movie the tone kind of reminded me
of the movie Brazil well it's the same
direction oh is it all right yeah okay
that's what I said it's Terry Gillian
okay yeah so I would like I love that
movie Brazil yeah but the totalitarian
Society with all the [ __ ] bureaucracy
and [ __ ] and him and his fantasy girl
and his fantasy life because he can't
really do it it's a good movie matter of
fact I think we reviewed Brazil a long
time ago but matter of fact
um
he would uh Terry Gilliam was actually
like wanting to do Brazil and like
shopping it around in the early 80s and
he couldn't get any funding for it which
I kind of feel like is that happens a
lot with poor Terry Gilliam because he's
like so imaginative like the crazy
movies that comes out of his are always
like a risk so he couldn't get anybody
to fund it so he thought to himself well
maybe I'll make a family film like maybe
that would be less of a risk and and
this is the movie that came out of it uh
this is technically
a family film but uh this is the only
purportedly children's film that I've
ever seen where the main character kids
parents spoiler alert explode at the end
so you know what I mean so like I said
it is Terry Gilliam that we're talking
about somebody would drop a comment in
the comment section so we can see if the
comments are working or not yeah it's
working it's working okay yeah it's
working because there's a bunch of
people in there no comments all right
yeah Danny rolling said David Warner's
character's Hidden Fortress was a pretty
cool idea everything about this was a
cool idea and I didn't even realize well
I was because I saw this movie
probably a million times on cable came
out in theaters in 81 and was actually
like pretty successful I saw it on cable
as a kid and didn't remember anything of
it yeah and I saw it a million times I
was like obsessed with this [ __ ]
movie like in the early 80s and so I saw
it like a million times and but I hadn't
seen it for probably like 20 25 years so
I was really excited when I saw that HBO
Max had it because I was like oh man I
really really want to re-watch that it's
like I kind of didn't want to re-watch
it because I'm like what if it's not as
good as I remember because like I said I
[ __ ] adored this movie when I was a
kid but I'm happy to report that I liked
it just as much and I remembered like so
much about it I mean so much of this
[ __ ] movie
I don't know why but like things from
this movie have stuck well for one thing
the ending theme song The George
Harrison song which is called dream away
that [ __ ] gets stuck in my head all the
time and now that I've watched the movie
again now that's gonna be stuck in my
head for the next 20 years probably it's
a it's an ear worm and David Warner in
particular
as kind of like the evil you know the
evil guy especially like the devil or
whatever but um he's just like so
[ __ ] great in this that one of his
best lines and I don't know why this
makes me laugh so much but there's like
one part where him and his like little
henchmen or whatever he says something
because like something really cool like
evil happens and he's like I feel very
very good and then one of his like
henchmen is like I'm sorry Master and
he's like it'll pass it'll pass and it's
like I don't know why that like is like
delivery there like cracks me up but
he's [ __ ] great in this even though
he actually wasn't the first choice I
think Jonathan price uh was the first
choice who would have been great too
because I love Jonathan praise but David
Warner like [ __ ] kills it this thing
I had forgotten how much of a [ __ ]
stacked cast this [ __ ] has everybody's
in this [ __ ] movie and I kind of see
the balls Shelley Duvall is in this
movie
um Ralph Richardson and since we Sean
Connery is in this movie they were like
Terry Gilliam was like [ __ ] over the
moon that they actually got Sean Connery
to be in this [ __ ] because the story I
love this story I was reading this
there's a really really long article I
think it's on Gizmodo
um about like the making of this movie
it's like an excerpt from a book and
it's really long and it's fascinating
this movie was like uh it was a [ __ ]
and a half like to get made like I said
it was just it's amazing that it ever
got made and that it only cost five
million dollars because yeah that's it
yeah it costs five million dollars yeah
movie looks like it's good the movie's
great and it made and it made a [ __ ] ton
like it was actually really successful
which is weird because it's weird it's a
weird movie yeah but um the when they
wrote the script like the character of
Agamemnon because I'll get into like the
plot if you haven't seen it later on but
the character of Agamemnon is in there
and in the script they actually wrote as
a joke you know Agamemnon takes off his
helmet and we see that it's Sean Connery
or some cheaper alternative like like
they wrote that in the script like as a
joke they're like we never thought in a
million years that we would get actual
Sean Connery because that's who they
wanted legit he was in zardos that's
true yeah well they said that is
but it's like it well the thing I think
they kind of got it I guess because he'd
been in zardas and he'd been in uh this
was the same year he did uh Outland or
whatever that movie was yeah and um so I
think that maybe he was on a little bit
of a downswing like on his career and so
he was more open to doing the movie you
know what I'm saying and actually he
didn't take a salary for this movie he
just wanted like a percentage of the
gross yeah because they like met him
like they met him on a golf course or
something like that and said hey want to
be in our movie and he's just like sure
why not you know what I mean so I
thought that was like kind of cool and
uh yeah and they said that he was like
super cool about it too but I mean he's
not in it a huge amount they only had
him like for a few weeks because if you
don't know the plot of this movie it's
okay
it's kind of like it's a Terry Gilliam
so it's kind of like it's a lot crazy
but they're they're it's crazy but
they're yeah if you watch Brazil it
seems crazy but no there's a lot of
intelligent [ __ ] commentary in it and
this movie reminds me a lot of Brazil
from what I was able to see it what I've
what you know what I mean I saw a few
scenes that was it I was like it's like
something kind of out I was going like
the tone is like Brazil the writing is
similar I didn't realize it was the same
guy yeah it's Terry Gilliam well yeah
because Brazil this came out in 81.
Brazil came out in 85 and then
Adventures of Baron Munchausen which
Hugo just mentioned came out in 88 and
he considers that his like Trilogy of
imagination or something like that
because all three of those movies are
like kind of similar so but this was his
attempt at a family film which like I
said I guess it is because the main
character is a kid like a boy named
Kevin
and so Kevin is like really into history
like he's a history nerd and it so
happens that let me see if I can where
what angle should I come at this from
okay so there's a gang of little people
and this gang of little people are
actually they actually helped create the
Earth
um they're actually the like tree and
Shrubbery people like they're the ones
that came up with all the trees and
shrubs and everything like that so
they're kind of like under their
employees of the Supreme Being or God
they don't call them God they call them
the Supreme Being
so um but they found out that well they
did all these trees and stuff like that
and they feel like they didn't really
get any appreciation
so a bunch of them got together and they
stole a map from the Supreme Being which
had all of these like Rifts in space
time
and they came up with this plan that
they're going to use this map to go to
all these different historical eras and
steal [ __ ] like take art from like
various time periods like historical
events and things like that and then
like slip back into a time portal and no
one will catch them and then they'll be
super super wealthy so this is their
plan and in the course of that they end
up in the bedroom of Kevin like in the
20th century in Britain they just kind
of like come busting through his uh
through his wardrobe there
and end up taking Kevin Along on this
journey with them so they kind of like
go through all these historical well
they're not all historical because some
of them are Fantastical too like so they
meet like real people I guess kind of
like you know Napoleon and Agamemnon and
people like that but they also meet
Robin Hood who may or may not be a real
person uh they get on they're on the
Titanic
um you know it was [ __ ] like that and
then like toward the end they go to the
time of Legends so there's like Giants
and ogres and stuff like that but it's a
crazy crazy [ __ ] movie and I don't
know what it is about it but I love it
so much oh and also David Warner is
um is evil I mean and he he lives in
this uh The Fortress of what's it called
Fortress of ultimate darkness which is
kind of like at the ends of the Earth
kind of situation it's like the way they
find it is like really cool because
they're they're in this kind of like I
guess it's like a desert there's like a
desert with all in the time of Legends
and they think that there's nothing
around because it just looks like this
big flat thing with all these like weird
monster skeletons everywhere but then
like there's like a like a mirror type
situation like you break it and then
it's like behind there and so they get
in now apparently there was a lot of
stuff that was supposed to be in this
movie that they either decided that they
couldn't fit it in or um they didn't
have enough money to shoot it there was
supposed to be one sequence with like a
whole bunch of spider women which
actually sounded cool when Terry Gilliam
described it but I think they shot some
of it but I don't know they cut it for
whatever reason or they couldn't do it
the way they want to do it or something
like that but I don't know they're like
I said there's just something like
really really cool about this [ __ ]
movie and Hugo said uh David Warner is a
great villain in time after time yeah I
just did a whole video about that on
scare Salon like the other day because
he makes a great uh Jack the Ripper
and let me see oh slasher Fred said
there was a movie that I remember
watching called Mother Goose Rock and
rhyme I remember that and Shelley Duvall
played the role of Little Bo Peep yeah I
remember that I remember that
maybe you you and me are probably the
only people that remember that [ __ ]
slasher Fred also said this movie kind
of reminds me of the very original movie
The Hobbit that was part of the original
Lord of the Rings animated Trilogy yeah
this is and I think I was watching both
of those around the same time because I
watched that uh the Ralph bed was the
Ralph bakshi one right the animated
Hobbit I watched that a bunch of times
too but I mean like I said the cast of
this is incredible so John Cleese is in
it as Robin Hood even though what's
crazy is that Michael Palin it's because
okay so Michael Palin and John Cleese
are both in this but
I think they kind of got mad because
this movie kind of gets lumped together
with like a Monty Python movie and he's
like we don't really like to call it a
Monty Python movie unless all of us are
in it and you know Eric idle isn't in it
and stuff like that so they're like
we're just in it because it's a Terry
Gillian movie I'm not because it's a
Monty Python movie so John Cleese
actually plays Robin Hood even though
Michael Palin wrote they wrote it he was
the one that wrote the script him and
Terry Gilliam and Michael Palin was
supposed to be Robin Hood but then they
came and said well John Cleese is
actually like a more bankable name so we
want him to be Robin Hood so then
Michael Palin had to write that other
part with him and Shelley Duvall like
where where they're kind of like they're
actually in two different time periods
because they're on they're in the Middle
Ages I think or the Renaissance or
something like that and then they're
later on they're on the Titanic like
playing different characters like many
centuries hence but they're the same
personalities which I thought was like
kind of funny yeah I didn't get to see
it I gotta see this [ __ ] again man we
yeah it's like we I really it was bummed
out that you couldn't like watch it but
it was like it was getting so late and I
was like man I really gotta start
watching this because like I said it's
long and it's like I did the right thing
because we had to do the show I didn't
really really want to fall asleep you
know what I mean tell them about it I I
can vouch it's a good movie I mean I saw
it as a kid several times and I remember
liking it but I don't remember anything
about the movie and I probably missed
out on a lot of the a lot of the uh the
meanings behind [ __ ] you know because I
was a kid when I saw it probably 14
maybe yeah it's a I will attack a bunch
of innuendo and [ __ ] I will attest that
there is a lot you get a lot more seeing
it as an adult yeah because I mean I got
most of it as a kid but
I mean it was written by adults and it
was written by Michael Palin and Terry
Gilliam so it kind of has
it's a kids movie I guess but not really
I don't know I was like I was I was
looking at um because I'm always kind of
interested how like people my age
and when they have kids and they start
showing uh their kids like movies that
they liked when they were growing up but
I was kind of curious if they liked them
or not and I was like reading a um a
comment on this article that I was
reading earlier about the making of this
movie and the guy said that he had loved
this movie so much when he was a kid and
he was very very excited to show it to
his son
um and his son was nine and he said my
son loved this movie he said he just
thought it was [ __ ] great so maybe it
transcends time period you know what I
mean yeah I feel like maybe it's one of
those a good movie will it yeah I mean
definitely I mean I've seen reaction
videos of people that you know we're
basically gen Z all right watching the
old original Star Wars Trilogy and they
just [ __ ] love it tear jerking at the
end and everything you know so it's just
some movies last you know they love the
characters and the
and you know other movies don't some
movies are just kinda
they kind of age out you know but a
classic movie will last forever pretty
much and this one I think works so well
because it's a fantasy and because it's
so out there like it's not really of any
particular time period so I think you
can kind of like enjoy it like it's not
dated at all I don't think well some
dated movies also age real well like I
love Bella goes He Boris Karloff The
Black Cat movie could stand today that
was pre-haze code creepy [ __ ] happens in
it
it's very I don't know 20s or 30s
looking and uh
yeah it's a very much a movie of its
time but it's kind of uh
as a futuristic satanic kind of feel to
it and just morally [ __ ]
twisted
and uh and it was I think that was one
of the movies that made them came up
with that code
with the necrophilia and the incest yeah
torture and human sacrifice and Elite
people [ __ ]
sacrificing humans on to consecrate
ground to build [ __ ] high-tech
satanic [ __ ]
temples on it you know what I mean it
just you never saw anything like that
after once that Haze code [ __ ] came
in in in into play Boris Boris Carla
Bella goes you the black cat that [ __ ]
[ __ ] aged well aged very well
so a good movie will do that even if
it's dated
yeah it just ends up being a period
piece kinda you're like oh I mean what
honestly one of my favorite sequences in
this movie which I which I when I was
watching it last night it still looks
incredible today is when they go to the
time of Legends you know what I mean
which obviously isn't a real historical
time period but you know it's it exists
so just roll with it so they go there
and they're on this ship with an ogre
and his wife and you know they're all
gonna get eaten
but then they kind of like uh you know
outwit the ogres and kind of throw them
overboard and then they're like on the
ship and they're trying to like you know
Steer the ship in the direction they
want to go and then just for no reason
whatsoever like the ship starts going
like that and then you see that the ship
is actually on the head of a humongous
giant and he just like comes out the
water with this [ __ ] ship on his head
with all this I was like oh my God I
loved that so much when I was a kid I
thought that was so [ __ ] cool but
it's like everything about this is cool
and I can't believe
I only just found out today that this
was shot for five million dollars that
blows my [ __ ] mind that blows my mind
I mean a lot of this
I don't know it's I feel like it's more
like the fantasy stuff is more toward
the end because at the beginning you
have more of them going through like
different time periods like I said you
just go to like Sherwood Forest and then
you know John Cleese is there as Robin
Hood being like super super polite which
is really really funny you have like a
sequence with Ian Holm uh you know from
Alien
uh you know he plays the uh the Android
yeah and uh he plays Napoleon yeah and
he's like obsessed with like
um with other other historical people
and he's like obsessed with height and
stuff but one of the funniest things
about that because I had almost
forgotten about that sequence one of the
funniest things about that sequence was
that he's sitting there watching like a
Punch and Judy like puppet show and he's
just like laughing his ass off at it and
you know meanwhile they're like um hey
like the Italian guy he's gonna
surrender so it's like you want to kind
of he's like what I'm watching the
puppets you know what I mean so he's
like watching all these uh different
um these kind of like different uh stage
shows and he's not really liking any of
them and then he tells the guy the thing
that he wants to he's like all he wants
to see is little things hitting each
other that was that's like his favorite
thing that's the only thing that he
finds entertaining is little things
hitting each other and for some reason I
thought that was very very funny all
because his French accent is it's not
bad but it's like you can tell that he's
like just not really trying to do a
French accent but just trying more to be
funny and it's like I just I don't know
I thought that was funny and then like
the whole sequence with um Sean Connery
being Agamemnon and he's like fighting a
[ __ ] Minotaur that whole sequence is
great they shot that in Morocco by the
way and uh you know the kid the kid
actually wants to stay there like in
ancient Greece because he liked the
history of it so much but you know the
the midgets kind of like uh you know
taken back with them and stuff as a
friend of midgets and [ __ ] one of the
leaders of the [ __ ] short guy Guild I
must come in and say that [ __ ] um the
whole thing about uh Napoleon Bonaparte
being short was not true he wasn't he
was nice but it's perpetuated I just
wanted to clear that up for you people
we just we disavow
Napoleon Bonaparte was actually above
above uh above average height and his
Imperial guards towered above him that's
really what the the translation says
uh but it was just British propaganda of
the time back then to try to make him
seem well he's a little short
[ __ ] no he's pretty big
and his Royal Guards were even bigger
that's what the statement said that's
the only reference to his height by a
witness
but uh he was not a short guy but I mean
they ran with it in this that was like
his whole yeah that was his whole thing
was like he was obsessed with other like
dictators and other uh leaders and stuff
and like how tall they were and like he
was taller than some of them and all I
forgot about this too but they actually
gave him because you know how there's
that uh common misconception of like him
with the hand and the yeah in the jacket
and they actually gave him like a fake
gold hand in this one too because that's
one of the things that the little people
steal like when they're taking all of
his [ __ ]
but so yeah but like I said they just
kind of like rolled with it
um honestly I really liked there's I
mean there's just so many [ __ ] great
sequences in this when they go to like
the Middle Ages and then they all get
captured by this other gang of robbers
and so all the little people are like
hanging from the tree like from the trap
and Randall who's David Rappaport the
reason that I wanted to do this was
because David Rappaport the the little
person actor was also in the bride which
we talked about on Sunday and then I was
like okay well we definitely got to do
Time Bandits because uh David rapport's
in that too so he plays kind of like the
leader of the gang like Randall
and he's like well you know just leave
this to me like we're robbers too so
we're like simpatico and so like they're
hanging there and they're like having
like a little thing off where they're
just like their robbers are like asking
them like how like horrible and shitty
they are and he's like yeah we're shitty
but and then it works and it works
they're just like oh you're also robbers
you know what I mean and it's just like
just funny and then they take them to
meet their boss and they're like you
want to meet the boss holy [ __ ] so you
like think it's like this real badass
and then like [ __ ] John Cleese comes
out as like the politest Robin Hood Ever
like shaking everyone's heads and [ __ ]
and it's just like oh my God it's so
[ __ ] great it's so [ __ ] great
um they're talking about a movie which I
don't think I ever saw actually
um Sasha Fred said there's an underrated
80s movie called in the land of far away
that was like a pre Harry Potter that
was about this boy who's whisked away
from his cruel Foster family and learns
he's a prince with Christian Bale
isn't that interesting I don't think
that I ever heard of that
so I'm gonna have to look that up now
because that's now really interesting
and I'm really interested uh slashford
also brings up my best friend is a
vampire yeah I remember that one very
similar to the classic cartoon series
count duckula
and then Zach says I used to be bored to
death when my dad would bring home old
movies he watched as a kid but now that
I appreciate filmmaking so much more old
movies is basically all I watch well
they're all going to be old movies
because that's true because each year
you're only going to have two or three
real good ones so you know and it's kind
of been that way over decades and kind
of getting worse so there are times
where
the Hollywood System kind of revived
itself a little bit like in the 80s with
Spielberg and Lucas they kind of made a
comeback people realize don't realize
that those were a tour [ __ ] Indie
directors that the studios picked up
really a real Studio director from the
[ __ ] 80s in the 70s [ __ ] most of
what they were making [ __ ] sucked all
right a lot of the movies from the era
before that were kind of like good indie
films you know uh you know if I can um
uh Easy Rider and stuff like that or or
[ __ ] that was just [ __ ] really cool
for the time like bullet you know which
I don't know exactly who made bullet but
bullet was ahead of its time
um Rosemary's Baby stuff like that and
all that [ __ ] was very unusual for the
studios of the time that's why you
remember them most of the [ __ ] that they
made was just [ __ ] forgotten well they
were just trying to make a buck yeah you
know today they didn't really worry
about oh we were people gonna like
remember this 20 years from now I think
they really gave a [ __ ] so just in
general if you want to see good movies
they're going to be old movies
there's not enough well because well
because time has winnowed out the crap
yep that's why yep so that's why that's
why I'm saying that yeah oh because
you're gonna go back to movies that have
[ __ ] survived over time and it's
going to be almost all old ones the only
thing that's made in the past couple
years that I thought was great was that
damn Viking movie was [ __ ] badass
which I still haven't bought
um
[ __ ] uh art of self-defense and
[ __ ] uh vivarium I thought were great
uh and those were all little those are
Irish flicks I think at least one of
them was bavarium was an Irish filmmaker
yeah so these were all unusual movies
you know uh and will they stand the test
of time yeah but Varian will stand the
test of time it won't be the mainstream
yeah it won't be mainstream I love that
movie it'll just I don't know what it
was like a weird ass [ __ ] Outer
Limits uh [ __ ] episode you know weird
weird an artist self-defense weird see
weird [ __ ] is good if it's weird in the
right ways if you're just gonna do weird
for weirdness's sake then that then
that's not good that doesn't work out
but like I said I kind of feel like the
reason people talk still talk about
Terry Gilliam
um because you know it's because of
movies like this he had a very
particular vision and it's kind of weird
and it's kind of out there and he really
kind of went the extra mile I was gonna
say this movie cost five million dollars
to make and they mortgaged their office
like George Harrison he had like a um a
company called handmade films and they
mortgage the office to get the money to
make this movie because they wanted to
make it so bad and
so I mean you know he has like like I
said he has a particular vision and he
tried you know obviously when they
released it
they were trying to get him like I said
they didn't really like the ending it's
like you know you can't end a kids movie
with like the kids parents exploding but
he was like the hell I can't you know
what I mean and they showed it to test
audiences of kids and kid that was the
kid's favorite part like their parents
blowing up at the end don't touch it
it's evil yeah that they both touch it
and then they explode it's like that was
so I used to love that too because
they're like man it's like do you even
know kids it's like all kids like have
fantasies about get rid of their parents
it's like the kids will [ __ ] love
that they did they did so they like they
actually let him do that so that was one
of my favorite things about the film too
is that it ended with like the kids
parents exploding
so I don't know I just thought that was
so great because it was a piece of like
concentrated evil you know at the end
and also we got to talk too about like
[ __ ] uh Ralph Richardson as the
Supreme Being uh you know God
essentially who was so [ __ ] great and
uh he comes in they said that when he
shot the movie like they gave him the
script and they said he had like a red
pen and he would go through the script
like Crossing out and rewriting some of
his dialogue and he said like they said
he said with very with a lot of
confidence God wouldn't say that you
know so they're like well obviously we
got the right guy to play this part they
said he was very much like a British
school Master like he played it like
that and I thought that was so [ __ ]
great but just I love the concept of
this movie this just a concept is so
weird and I just I love that this movie
got made because the concept is just so
out there like if somebody is not
seen this movie or heard about it and
you tell them what it's about it sounds
batshit insane
but
it still works it totally totally works
um and I'm not really sure what kind of
alchemy like made that happen it was
just like a great cast a great script it
looks great it has like a very
particular look to it and it's just like
I don't know I just I just love this
movie so much and and I'm glad that I
watched it again because I was kind of
afraid like to watch it again because I
was like what if what if I don't like it
as much as I liked it as I liked when I
was a kid because like I said I was
obsessed with this [ __ ] movie when I
was little
well I wasn't little
because I probably didn't see it I saw
it when I was 10 10 or 11 must have been
like whenever it came on cable because
it came out in theater in 81 and I don't
think I saw it in the theater although I
may have now that I'm thinking about it
maybe I did but I'm pretty sure I saw it
a year or two after that so I would have
been like maybe 11 years old when I
first said I was like obsessed with it
because it was on like HBO all the time
and I saw a million million times and
for whatever reason lines from it have
just been stuck in my head ever since
and like I said the whole David Warner
thing and the whole like all like most
of his dialogue is stuck in my head and
like just some random lines in there
that
that I just remember for whatever reason
like like Michael Palin saying no I
don't have to wear the special anymore
you know what I mean it's just [ __ ] like
that which I didn't really get when I
was a kid but like now I'm just like oh
it's dirty I get it but you know what I
mean
but uh yeah let's see
Jeffy Hart said sadly I believe about 30
of films don't make the cut every time
the medium changes due to the money
Studios rights owners need to make the
transference yeah and I kind of that's
kind of a shame too because
I mean most movies that I've been that I
look for like in the course of like
reviewing and stuff like that most
things
are out on DVD at least but when you get
to has it been upgraded to Blu-ray then
it's like a lot harder because a lot of
movies that I've been looking for
haven't been upgraded to Blu-ray like
old ones unless they're like Classics or
but that's why I'm glad we have you know
companies like blue underground and
arrow and stuff like that that are
really committed to
getting these cult movies and doing like
the best possible [ __ ] that they can
like do in really nice transfers and
really nice extras and kind of go in the
extra mile to get that kind of [ __ ] so
I'm glad that there's little companies
out there doing that
you know to
because you know it's easy to see big
Hollywood movies I mean you can see that
anywhere it's yeah I think it's much
more uh you know
much more doing God's work if you go
back and like kind of find some
forgotten ones you know none if it sucks
you don't have to like do like you know
you don't have to like spend all this
time and money like rescuing a piece of
[ __ ] from obscurity but you know some
cult movies are actually like really
should be like seen by more people yeah
Joe Weevil said nipples for men yeah
slugs he created slugs yeah that kind of
[ __ ] nipples for men yeah I'd forgotten
about that line too
uh all right so
um are you ready to
uh what drop that [ __ ] down yeah shut
that [ __ ] down
I got none more I can say about it I
didn't see it yeah because you only saw
like little parts of it yeah we'll have
to like watch it again at some point
honestly you know what would be cool
it'd be cool if we could watch like all
three of them if we could watch like
this movie in Brazil and um and um what
you call it and uh I don't know I don't
know what everyone what did I just say
Adventures of bear and Munchausen yeah
yeah because I haven't seen that in a
long time either so I kind of want to
watch that one again
but and I don't think we reviewed that I
think we we reviewed Brazil a long time
ago but I don't think we've done Baron
Munchausen so maybe we should do that
one of these days I was just excited
about doing this one because one I saw
it on HBO Max and two I was reminded
that it was on HBO Max because we just
watched the bride and that also had
David Rappaport in it who's also in this
movie so I was like I was just kind of
like bummed out that you that you
couldn't uh watch it with me I was busy
I couldn't we'll watch it at some point
but yeah so um okay so that'll do it for
today's match today now tomorrow is
going to be the main show and we're
doing going back to True Crime we're
doing a zodiac Revisited oh yeah okay
yeah I heard that there's some some [ __ ]
because there's been like some kind of
new info I'm not really sure how I feel
about it yet but we'll there's certainly
some guys he's convinced 100 that he
knows who it is yeah yeah yeah so we'll
kind of get into that we'll talk about
the old case and and stuff because we
did the Zodiac but it was like a long
time ago so we'll kind of like do a
revisit on it so that should be fun but
yeah so thanks everybody for dropping by
this evening and hopefully you can come
by and uh do see us for the show
tomorrow and uh we'll see you guys then
good night